[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
sure today with something I'll say today
was the best day of my life say you see
the best day of your life
[Music]
seriously okay I don't even know where
I'm gonna begin to tell the story I can
tell it you a Nutella
oh I can tell okay good I got working
out by unit in the morning with the
camera in my face which is quite a
daunting then I was I was sipping on a
blindfold I've been up all night and I
was lid outside into the garden
yeah opposite direction and you can
remove it
[Music]
what is that because what you were doing
all of last night yeah amazing yo it
okay let's give it context you got to
give it a coup the story context well I
don't know where the story begins
that's what okay name you tell us sir
okay okay yesterday I was bored and I
came to bag you while you were doing
those financials and then I was like
maybe gonna make a cool video to find
out from your side how did you feel
about canceling our wedding just burning
I mean piss painting was a really
difficult decision having Chavis Burnett
I feel like I'm stuck with those nerves
of anticipation Alice because everything
is was ready to go I'm sorry and then
honestly your answer made me sad and I
was like [ __ ] there has to be some way
to show you how much I care about you
and like that I really don't want to be
able to do something in the space of not
being able to do this wedding so I then
went into the lounge and consulted Joey
Joey what would you do you just chased
his tail but that actually gave me
inspiration because it gave me the idea
that you should never stop chasing your
gods then waited for you to go to see
it seems like she's sleeping already
what I'm gonna do I'm just gonna double
check and then I'm gonna get up start
these missions 30 Joey joins and I snuck
out a fade I try to convince Joey to
come with me he declined so I went alone
I got my wheelbarrow I went to my
outside tool box and you know that means
getting it you love your tool box that's
not so weird but yeah I do I really love
that tool box
I carry much into the garage
[Music]
I think that it's clear with all of this
chaos it's time to make a list I made a
list of everything that I thought it
should be and a waiting list
okay let me tell the story okay my first
thing on the list was a priest but I was
like I really don't know what to do for
the outside scratch that out then I do
within a day and then we have done to
the rings gaps and I are both extremely
musical people and my thought is that if
I had to create rings out of the guitar
strings get them to the right size
assign them dancer they smooth we have
it
three an Delta
[Music]
maybe that sounds so cute
stop interrupting okay for the bad
[Music]
during Vera this is Joey's Josie and on
the back a little pouch and inside I'll
taste the rings and he'll come running
down the aisle and deliver us the ring
six games
[Music]
this is insane when I started I didn't
even know if this was gonna work but
this is quite an impressive crowd seven
just married sign
oh and finally to surprise cows at this
stage I pulled an all-nighter
[Music]
[Applause]
and then we're tonight I set up all of
these ridiculous cardboard cutouts I for
the priests the idea was to use Jonah
he's garrison my roommates in Los
Angeles so Center Virtual head up by a
zoom and got Jonah to to plugin and the
script ear head for that was from the
mr. bean maybe temptin areas yeah well I
didn't know I have no time to any other
preps and and then I came in to surprise
you it's all waiting
[Music]
look there's all our guests [ __ ] Jason
on the guitar granny
Casey's there in the back so what now
baby now you get ready and I sweep gaps
and I both aren't religious but we're
aware of the tradition around marriage
and the need for our families and the
celebration of coming together nests but
this is our way of celebrating our love
and
coming to given us in a way that anyone
can be witnessed it
the audience is our witness did it
finish the story again the story so [ __ ]
you looked beautiful
walking down the aisle oh my god am I
gonna cry like this would be awkward if
I cried then Jonah said he's bernard he
does some lines then we put on our rings
which felt really like real don't you
think you know what and if we weren't
having as so called legal awaiting
marriage ceremony at the end of the year
this would have been the perfect wedding
that makes me happy
and it was the perfect day to you me in
the pool
but you needed to get out of those smart
let's so that we could climb the roof
I'm Albert
[Music]
and it seems the left bow
ah
dodo
seems to left my heart
outside
[Applause]
[Music]
should we leave that thing up there yes
just for good we just leave it leave it
there so everyone can always see before
we in this video please subscribe to my
channel it's just a simple click of a
button
I've linked to below it's also at the
end of this video in an annotation card
and another turn your notification bell
on don't forget your awesome drew and
I'll see you next week
I swear that I
this is with
[Music]
I swear that
you laugh I